hey Gary be here so the more I kind of
live my life and do my business and do
vaynermedia of my library Gary
Vaynerchuk and personal brand and wine
business and consulting for all these
clients companies the more and more it's
getting obvious and I think plenty
people understand this but I wanted to
show my two thoughts on this that your
time as a person is what's now valuable
it's the only scarcity in the market
right I mean information is widely
available opinions are a time a dozen
entertainment is coming at us at all
angles the cost to make them is zero the
cost of the libera them is zero the cost
to promote them is zero so what can you
really monetize well what you're gonna
monetize brands and companies is your
effort and your caring brand time is
what is going to make money in the
future actually spending time with your
fans taking them on tour recording a
song with them you know talking about
them having lunch with them having
dinner with them quino's shaking hands
skyping your time your effort to your
community is where you're gonna monetize
and the more people realize that the
customer service aspect of your business
is where the money is going to be the
quicker they're going to be successful
in the new world where almost
everything's value is dropping so
quickly I mean you can't sell
information can you but what you can
sell is your time and what happens is
people then become caring the more time
you give away the more they thank you
and then they start getting into the
Thank You business so clearly you can't
sell all your time but the more you give
it away for free
like live-streaming with your fan base
something I've been doing more and more
of the more people appreciate it the
more they understand that has a value
the more they know that you're not
spending time with somebody else or with
your family you're with them you're
giving them your time and that
engagement and the lack of fear of
overexposure is where the opportunity is
going to
be going forward with something a lot of
businesses and a lot of personal brands
bands products everything need to really
think about enormous opportunity your
time not the most scalable thing but
there's at least so much of it and it's
a want to a lot of people they'll become
quite quite valuable brand time is about
to get really valuable you know those
people that show up at parties and get
paid athletes and celebrities that get
paid a fortune for appearances we're
gonna see micro versions of that
enormous economy behind it and a lot of
interesting scalability with Skype and
Ustream and these kind of aspects it's
going to be quite fascinating the brand
the product of time product time is
about to become quite interesting